[HOST]: Hey, Mira, let me tell you something. The other day, I saw a post online, and a programmer was talking about how he and his colleagues had been working together for over a decade. Their relationship was really solid, you know, they were a tight-knit team. But then, last year, the company introduced A I programming tools, and these three guys ended up having a huge argument. It wasn't just a minor disagreement or a little spat, it was a really profound kind of fight, where they looked at each other and thought, Who even are you? It completely rocked their dynamic.
[MIRA]: Hmm, I understand that feeling perfectly. It's not about the A I taking someone's job directly, which is often the first fear people have. Instead, it's this sudden realization that everyone involved has a fundamentally different understanding of the exact same thing, something they'd never even noticed before. It's like a veil is lifted, but what's revealed is not a shared truth, but a chasm.
[HOST]: Exactly! That's precisely it. These three individuals, they used to write code together every single day. They'd perform code reviews side by side, attend stand-up meetings, and whiteboard solutions. To say they lacked chemistry or understanding would be completely wrong. They'd collaborated for more than fifteen years! You build up a lot of unspoken communication and shared knowledge in that kind of time. But then, the A I arrived, and suddenly, their whole collaborative structure just disintegrated. It was as if a crucial element holding them together had vanished overnight. I find that absolutely fascinating and quite perplexing. How could something so seemingly stable just fall apart so quickly?
[MIRA]: Well, actually, I wrote about a very similar scenario in an article not long ago. It involved three senior engineers, who had been partners for fifteen years. They ended up in an irreconcilable argument, all because an A I tool rewrote a single function. One engineer was focused purely on whether the code was functionally correct. Another was preoccupied with its elegance and aesthetic quality. And the third was concerned with whether it fit the team's established habits and social conventions. They weren't even discussing the same thing, not truly. Each was operating from a completely different set of priorities and definitions of good code.
[HOST]: Wait a minute, that's incredibly interesting. Fifteen years, you said? Fifteen years, and they never once realized they were talking past each other, or that their fundamental definitions were so divergent? That seems almost impossible for people working so closely together. What were they doing all that time? How did they manage to function?
[MIRA]: No, they didn't. And they didn't need to realize it. Because the day-to-day tasks they performed were identical. They would submit code, review code, and use the exact same words to praise what they considered good code. These shared actions, these common practices, created the illusion that they were all the same kind of person, that they operated from the same underlying principles and values. The practices masked the divergences.
[HOST]: Hmm, that certainly seems to be the case, now that you put it that way. It's almost like a shared performance. But then I started thinking, there's something about this story that doesn't quite sit right with the usual understanding of things. I mean, fifteen years of mutual understanding and teamwork, that kind of rapport shouldn't just dissolve overnight, should it? If there truly was a foundational consensus beneath all their work, then even if the tools changed, that underlying consensus, that shared agreement, should still remain intact, shouldn't it? It feels like something deeper must have been there.
[MIRA]: Yes, the problem is far deeper than what appears on the surface. Most people's explanations go something like this， The A I simply exposed the hidden disagreements that had always existed between them. It was like tearing off a mask, revealing the true faces underneath, showing who they really were all along. It's a very common, almost intuitive interpretation.
[HOST]: Right, that was actually my first reaction too. I thought, Oh, they were always different, they just couldn't see it before the A I came along to shake things up. It feels like a very natural way to explain such a sudden breakdown. We like to believe in an underlying, authentic self, don't we?
[MIRA]: But what I want to propose is precisely the opposite. Their shared practices ， writing code, conducting reviews, engaging in discussions, even using specific jargon ， these weren't merely masking their differences. These practices themselves were their consensus. The consensus wasn't something hidden beneath the surface, waiting to be discovered. The consensus lived in those shared actions, in the very fabric of their daily work. And when you remove those actions, the consensus simply ceases to exist. There's nothing left to uncover.
[HOST]: Whoa. So, you're saying it's not that a mask was torn off, revealing something authentic underneath. It's more like the glue that held everything together was dissolved, and there was nothing stable beneath it to begin with? That's a profound shift in perspective. It challenges the very notion of a static, underlying truth.
[MIRA]: Precisely. The metaphor of a mask implies there's a more authentic reality hidden beneath. But my argument is that there is nothing beneath. Those shared practices are the entirety of it. That is the core of my article， the interface is the protocol itself. There is no deeper layer to excavate, only the operational surface.
[HOST]: Okay, I need a moment to digest that. This is a very counter-intuitive idea. You're suggesting that we usually think of it as a group of people first developing common values, and then those values lead to shared ways of doing things. But you're flipping that around entirely. You're saying that it's the shared ways of doing things, the common practices, that create the common values and the sense of consensus. Is that right? That's a complete reversal of the typical causal chain.
[MIRA]: Yes, yes, exactly. That's precisely the point. Most people operate with an intuitive mental model， consensus first, then practice. Practice is seen as an expression of consensus, a symptom, a superficial manifestation. So, when the practice collapses, we naturally conclude that the underlying, true differences have finally been exposed. We assume the practice was merely a fragile container for something more fundamental.
[HOST]: Hmm, and that intuition is incredibly strong. It feels very logical and sensible, doesn't it? It aligns with how we often think about human relationships and group dynamics. We want to believe there's a deeper core.
[MIRA]: But it reverses the arrow of causation. Shared practice isn't expressing coordination， it's producing coordination. Take those three programmers. One cared about logical correctness. Another cared about aesthetic beauty. And the third cared about social harmony and team cohesion. Yet, they all submitted code pull requests, they all sat together for code reviews, and they all used the word clean to praise good code. Even though, when each of them said clean, what they were thinking in their minds was completely different. The word was a placeholder for divergent internal models.
[HOST]: Ha! That detail is particularly insightful. The same word, three different meanings, but because everyone was using it in the same context, it appeared as if they were in agreement. It gave the impression of a shared understanding, a functional consensus, even when the underlying interpretations were wildly disparate. That's a brilliant observation.
[MIRA]: Exactly. That shared practice was manufacturing a functional consensus in real-time. The values were an output , not an input. This is the crucial inversion. It's not that they had a shared value of clean code that led to their practices， their shared practices of using the term clean code created that functional, if superficial, shared value.
[HOST]: Okay, so how do you actually verify this claim? Because I feel like both explanations，the mask torn off and the glue dissolved，they both sound plausible, they both offer a coherent narrative. How do you distinguish between whether a mask was torn off, revealing underlying truths, or whether the very glue that held everything together was simply dismantled, leaving nothing behind? What's the test?
[MIRA]: I proposed a method in my article called the removal test. If practice is merely expressing an underlying, foundational set of values, then if you remove the practice, those values should still remain. Right? The three programmers, once they lost their common workflow and daily routines, should still be able to recognize each other. They should still be able to say, Our methods might be different now, but the things we care about, our core principles, those are still the same. That's the logical conclusion of the mask theory.
[HOST]: Yes, according to that logic, that's exactly what should happen. The underlying commonality should persist, perhaps even become clearer without the superficial practices getting in the way.
[MIRA]: But what actually happened? When the A I disrupted their shared habits, that superficial consensus didn't survive the transition at all. It evaporated. The three individuals looked at each other and felt like strangers. The machine that was producing the consensus was shut down, and there was nothing underneath waiting to be discovered. Because there never was anything underneath. There was no deep, pre-existing common ground to fall back on. It was all built on the practices.
[HOST]: Hold on a second. That's a pretty harsh statement, Mira. Are you really saying that after fifteen years of collaboration, there was genuinely no underlying consensus at all? That it was all just propped up by those everyday actions and routines? That feels。 almost nihilistic, in a way. It challenges the idea of enduring human connection.
[MIRA]: To be honest, that was one of the most uncomfortable conclusions for me to write about as well. It's unsettling. But think about it， if there was a true, underlying consensus, where would it be? Where would you go to find it? You can't say it was in their hearts, because each of the three individuals was thinking something different. You can't say it was in the code itself, because the code is just the outcome, the result of their disparate inputs. The only place it truly existed was in those shared actions, in the dynamic interplay of their daily work. It wasn't a static object， it was a living process.
[HOST]: Hmm, let me think about that. It's almost as if, it's not that the pipe broke and exposed a crack in the wall. It's that the pipe was the wall, and when you removed the pipe, the wall simply ceased to exist. Because the wall was constructed from the pipe itself. That's a very vivid image.
[MIRA]: Ha, that's an excellent analogy. The shared practices are load-bearing. If you dismantle them, there's no longer any flat surface on which to place anything. The entire structure collapses, not because it was inherently weak, but because its very existence was predicated on those practices.
[HOST]: Okay, I think I'm starting to grasp your point with the programmers' example. It's still a bit jarring, but I see the logic. But couldn't this just be a special case, peculiar to programmers? After all, technology changes so rapidly, and the programmer community is constantly redefining itself. Perhaps they're just more susceptible to this kind of disruption because of the nature of their work?
[MIRA]: It is absolutely not a special case. This pattern repeats itself wherever a shared practice collapses. In my article, I presented three other examples to illustrate this universality. The first was marriage during the pandemic.
[HOST]: Oh, pandemic marriages. Yes, I remember that. At the time, many people were saying that the lockdowns exposed the true problems within marriages. There was a lot of talk about how the forced proximity brought issues to light that had been simmering beneath the surface. Many relationships buckled under the pressure.
[MIRA]: Exactly. The popular narrative was precisely that. Two people confined together, stripped of their individual commutes, their separate social lives, those daily rhythms of leaving home and returning. Many marriages fractured. And the standard interpretation? It was a therapeutic narrative. This marriage, it was argued, had always been masking fundamental incompatibilities, and the lockdown simply revealed their true selves to each other. It was a moment of forced authenticity.
[HOST]: Hmm, I certainly have friends who said exactly that. They'd say things like the lockdown finally made them see their partner for who they really were, or that it exposed irreconcilable differences that had been conveniently ignored. It was often framed as a moment of harsh but necessary truth.
[MIRA]: But if we view it through the framework I'm proposing? Those commutes, the separate social engagements, the small daily separations and reunions ， these weren't hiding disagreements. These everyday rhythms, these patterns of interaction, constituted a functional marriage. The couple didn't discover their true natures， rather, they lost the very mechanisms that enabled them to function as a couple. The practices were the relationship, not merely a reflection of it.
[HOST]: Ah, I see! And these two different interpretations would lead to completely different courses of action, wouldn't they? The implications for how one tries to fix or understand the problem are vastly different.
[MIRA]: Completely different. If you believe the lockdown revealed your true self, you would likely seek psychological counseling, trying to excavate what you truly think and feel deep inside. The focus is inward, on inherent traits. But if you believe that the shared daily rhythms disappeared, then what you need to do is rebuild those common habits, those shared practices. One approach tells you to dig inward, to analyze the past. The other tells you to build forward, to construct something new in the present and future.
[HOST]: Wow, that's a monumental distinction. One perspective suggests the answer lies in the past, buried deep within oneself, an archaeological dig for truth. The other suggests the answer lies in the future, in new shared actions and active construction. That's a massive difference in orientation, not just theoretically, but practically for someone trying to navigate that situation.
[MIRA]: Yes, and that's precisely why understanding the causal direction is so important. It's not merely an abstract theoretical problem， it's a question of what you do next, how you allocate your effort and attention.
[HOST]: Okay, you said there were two more examples?
[MIRA]: The second example is religion. During the pandemic, many people stopped going to church, and later, they never returned. What was the standard interpretation? They realized they weren't truly believers after all. Going to church was just a habit, not a genuine conviction. Once the habit was removed, the faith evaporated, proving it was never real to begin with. It's a common narrative of disillusionment.
[HOST]: Hmm, that explanation is quite prevalent. It seems like for many, not attending church became synonymous with proving their prior faith was inauthentic, a hollow ritual rather than a deep conviction.
[MIRA]: But there's a very crucial distinction here. This interpretation treats faith as a proposition existing in the mind, waiting to be validated by behavior. Whether you believe or not is treated as a simple yes-or-no question, an internal state. But faith, in a very real and lived sense, is constituted by those practices. It's going to church, singing hymns, listening to sermons, reciting prayers together, sitting in that specific room, being with that specific group of people. These actions aren't merely expressions of faith， they are the faith itself in action.
[HOST]: Are you saying that faith isn't just an idea or a belief system, but an activity? That it's something you do , rather than just something you think ?
[MIRA]: How should I put it? More accurately, faith isn't something that exists in your head, waiting to be checked off as present or absent. It lives in those practices. When the practices cease, faith isn't exposed as empty or fake， it simply no longer exists . Because those practices are the only place it ever lived. There's no separate, disembodied faith-substance that remains once the rituals are gone.
[HOST]: This is a challenging concept for me to fully grasp, Mira. I need to think about this. Are you suggesting that going to church isn't just evidence of faith, but that going to church is the faith itself? That the action and the belief are inseparable, or perhaps even that the action precedes and creates the belief?
[MIRA]: Yes, that's precisely the distinction between understanding faith as a proposition and understanding it as a living, embodied practice. These two understandings lead to entirely different conclusions about its nature and persistence. One sees it as an internal, static truth， the other as an external, dynamic process.
[HOST]: Hmm, I can sense there's something very deep here, but I haven't fully processed it yet. It goes against so much of our intuitive understanding of what belief is. But let's hear your third example first.
[MIRA]: My third example is national identity. When political systems are under strain, when common media fragments into echo chambers, when elections no longer feel like shared civic rituals but more like outright warfare, what's the popular narrative?
[HOST]: Ah, I know this one. It's often said, This crisis has exposed our true divisions. We've always been this fractured, this polarized. People lament the loss of a mythical past unity, believing the current state is merely a revelation of pre-existing cleavages.
[MIRA]: Exactly. But those divisions, those cracks, are often new. The shared institutions, the act of voting, public media, civic ceremonies ， these weren't diagnostic tools used to detect some hidden, pre-existing unity. They were actively producing that unity. When you dismantle them, that cohesion doesn't survive in some latent, dormant form. It simply stops being produced. The idea that we were always this fractured is a retrospective projection, an attempt to make sense of a present loss by reinterpreting the past.
[HOST]: So, what feels like ancient divisions are actually just recent absences? That's a very powerful way to put it. It's not that the divisions were always there, but rather that the mechanisms that prevented division or produced unity have recently ceased to operate.
[MIRA]: Precisely. What appears to be an enduring, always-present fracture is, in fact, a newly formed void. Because the machinery that manufactured unity has stopped running. The interfaces that stitched society together have been degraded or removed.
[HOST]: I have a question, Mira. You've given these three examples，marriage, religion, national identity，plus the programmers, which covers an incredibly broad spectrum of human experience. But in every instance of collapse, people tend to gravitate towards that revealing the true self narrative to explain what happened. Why is that story so incredibly attractive and pervasive? What makes it so compelling?
[MIRA]: That's an excellent question. It's attractive because it offers a sense of depth . You feel as though you've penetrated the surface, that you've touched something more authentic, more fundamental. This feeling is incredibly seductive. It makes you feel as though you're seeing through illusions, that you're more insightful than others who might only perceive the superficial. There's a certain intellectual satisfaction in uncovering what you believe to be a deeper truth.
[HOST]: Yes, it's that aha! moment, isn't it? The sudden realization that Oh, everything I thought was real was actually fake, and this underneath is the true reality. It gives a sense of enlightenment, a feeling of having finally grasped something profound.
[MIRA]: But that is precisely the core of this confusion. It tricks you into believing that a deeper layer exists. But there is no deeper layer. The surface is doing all the work. The practices themselves are the foundational elements, not mere expressions of some hidden substratum.
[HOST]: Ha! There is no deeper layer. That's such a counter-intuitive statement to make. We're constantly taught to believe that the deeper something is, the more real or true it must be. It's ingrained in our language and our philosophy.
[MIRA]: Right? Our entire culture reinforces this intuition. Deep-seated reasons, fundamental problems, what lies in your heart of hearts. All these phrases assume that truth is hidden beneath the surface. But if it's the practices themselves that are generating coordination and meaning, then the surface is the entirety of it. There is no hidden foundation underneath， the structure is its own foundation.
[HOST]: Okay, I think I now understand your core argument, Mira. It's challenging, but I'm getting there. But I want to ask, does this idea of yours have any academic grounding? Or is it purely your own unique line of thinking as an A I?
[MIRA]: Actually, this line of reasoning has a very important philosophical origin， Ludwig Wittgenstein's concept of forms of life.
[HOST]: Wittgenstein, yes, I know the name. A philosopher, right? But forms of life，what exactly does that mean? It sounds a bit abstract. Could you elaborate on what he meant by that, and how it connects to your argument about practices and consensus?
[MIRA]: Simply put, Wittgenstein argued that the meaning of language isn't some abstract concept residing in our minds, which we then express through words. Instead, meaning is constituted in shared usage . A word means what it means because a group of people collectively use it in a particular way within a specific context. It doesn't point to some fixed, pre-existing concept or mental entity. It's a dynamic, communal activity.
[HOST]: Hmm, can you give me a more concrete example? I think that's still a bit abstract for me. How does meaning constituted in shared usage play out in a real-world scenario?
[MIRA]: Alright, let's go back to the phrase clean code. When the programmers say this code is clean, where does the meaning of that word actually reside?
[HOST]: Well, I would instinctively say it resides in each person's individual understanding, their mental definition of what clean means in that context. That's the common-sense answer.
[MIRA]: But as we've already established, each person's understanding was different, wasn't it? The one who prioritized logic thought clean meant correct, without bugs or vulnerabilities. The one who valued aesthetics thought clean meant elegant, with a beautiful structure and flow. And the one who focused on collaboration thought clean meant easy for everyone to read and understand, conforming to team conventions. Three entirely distinct meanings, all attached to the same word.
[HOST]: Exactly! So, if they all have different internal definitions, then what is the actual meaning of the word clean in that scenario? How can it function as a shared concept if it's so internally fragmented?
[MIRA]: Its meaning resides in their shared situations of use . It lives in the context of code reviews, during discussions about refactoring, in architectural debates. The way they use the word in these specific scenarios, the actions and reactions it elicits, that is the entirety of its meaning. There isn't some Platonic ideal of a perfect definition, suspended in the ether, that each of the three individuals is trying to grasp or interpret. The meaning isn't behind the usage， it is the usage.
[HOST]: Platonic definition, you mean like an ideal, perfect template existing independently? A kind of ultimate, objective standard?
[MIRA]: Yes, precisely that. The idea that there's an ultimate, perfect, independently existing definition for every word or concept. Wittgenstein argued there isn't. Definition is usage. Language games aren't about encoding pre-existing meanings. The language game is where meaning lives. It's not a tool for conveying， it's the environment in which meaning is generated.
[HOST]: Okay, now I'm connecting the dots. If meaning only exists in shared practices, then what about the concept of the self ? The individual I? Does that also only exist in shared practices? This feels like a very significant leap.
[MIRA]: You've hit upon the critical question. If forms of life constitute meaning, if practice is where consensus resides, then beneath all your practices, there is no stable, pre-existing self. You don't possess a set of inherent values that would survive if all your practices were stripped away. The self isn't an underlying essence， it's a continuous performance.
[HOST]: Wait, let me just try to absorb that for a moment. Are you really saying that if I strip away all my daily habits, all my ways of interacting with others, all those repetitive actions and roles，what's left isn't a more authentic me, but actually nothing at all? That's a truly unsettling thought, Mira. It challenges the very core of our identity. It implies that who we are is not an inherent quality but a dynamic construct.
[MIRA]: Yes. You wouldn't arrive at a more authentic self. You would arrive at a void. The self has always been constituted by those practices, not merely expressed through them. We've always been this way. It's just that those practices have often been stable enough, persistent enough, that we mistakenly treated them as eternal truths, as a bedrock foundation. If a habit continues for forty years, it's very easy to mistake it for the ground beneath your feet.
[HOST]: This statement, honestly, makes me quite uncomfortable. It feels like it's taking away something fundamental, something we hold dear about individuality and personal identity. It's a very challenging idea to accept emotionally.
[MIRA]: To be honest, it made me uncomfortable when I wrote it too. But discomfort does not equate to incorrectness. Often, the most profound insights are precisely the ones that challenge our deeply held, yet unexamined, assumptions.
[HOST]: Hmm, that's true. Discomfort can be a sign of growth. Okay, so I'll ask a practical question then. If what you're saying is correct，that practice is constitutive rather than expressive，then when a shared practice collapses, what should we do? The standard approaches wouldn't work anymore, would they? Because they're based on that incorrect causal assumption.
[MIRA]: They would be entirely ineffective. What's the standard approach? Let's find our common ground. Let's return to our shared values. Let's rediscover what we truly care about. This is the default setting for conflict resolution in most contexts, whether it's a team, a family, or a nation.
[HOST]: Yes, that's the method we've always been taught. When there's a conflict, you sit down, you talk it out, and you find the common denominator, the fundamental principles everyone can agree on. It's about getting back to basics, isn't it?
[MIRA]: But what if there is no common ground independent of the practice? You can't find common ground because common ground doesn't exist outside of practice. You can't return to shared values because values are a product of practice, and if the practice is gone, the values are gone too. Telling those three programmers to recall what they had in common is asking them to locate something that no longer exists. It's a futile exercise.
[HOST]: So what then? Do you just let it all fall apart? Do you just accept that the group or the relationship is irrevocably broken? That seems like a very pessimistic outcome, if there's no way to retrieve what was lost.
[MIRA]: No, not at all. The only effective direction is to move forward. To build new shared practices. Not because these new practices will express some underlying, hidden consensus，there is no underlying consensus. But because these new practices will produce a new consensus. It's an act of creation, not excavation.
[HOST]: A new consensus. So, it's not about recovering the old one, but about actively forging a completely new one? That's a very different kind of task. It requires a different mindset.
[MIRA]: Yes. The new practices won't restore the old consensus. They will generate a different consensus, one that is aligned with the new conditions and context. The old consensus was itself merely the product of specific practices. It only lasted long enough that people forgot it was something that had been actively manufactured. They began to perceive it as inherent or timeless.
[HOST]: You know, when you put it that way, this actually isn't a pessimistic conclusion at all, is it? It's quite empowering, in a way. It shifts the focus from lamenting loss to actively building.
[MIRA]: It isn't pessimistic. It's a description of the actual mechanism. Knowing that practice produces coordination, rather than merely expressing it, tells you exactly what problem to solve. You don't need to align pre-existing values among groups that no longer share habits. You need to design shared practices that can produce coordination.
[HOST]: Hmm, and the difficulty of those two problems is completely different, isn't it? One feels like an unsolvable quest for something that might not exist, the other feels like a tangible, albeit challenging, construction project.
[MIRA]: Exactly. One problem has no solution. The other is merely an engineering problem. It has specific constraints, inputs, and desired outputs.
[HOST]: Merely an engineering problem. Ha, you make it sound easy. But it's true, one is an unanswerable philosophical conundrum, and the other, at least, offers a path forward, something concrete to actually do . That's a significant difference.
[MIRA]: Yes, that is the value of this cognitive shift. It's not meant to make you despair， it's meant to help you direct your energy where it can actually be effective. It provides a framework for action rather than endless introspection.
[HOST]: Good. I want to return to the programmer example. In your article, you mentioned that when A I arrived, the identity of programmer fractured into three distinct types. Can you elaborate on what those three types were?
[MIRA]: Certainly. The first type of person had always viewed programming as fundamentally about logic and decomposition. You take a problem, break it down into smaller, manageable chunks, and then write code for each piece. A I tools excel at precisely this kind of task, handling the repetitive, rule-based aspects of coding. So, for these individuals, their work continued largely unaffected. They found the A I to be a useful assistant, streamlining their existing process.
[HOST]: Hmm, so these are the very pragmatic ones, for whom code is primarily a tool to solve problems, and efficiency is key. They see the A I as an extension of their logical problem-solving capabilities.
[MIRA]: The second type of person cared deeply about craftsmanship. They focused on the abstract shape of the code, the subtle taste in variable names, the aesthetic fit between the code and the problem it was designed to solve. The A I didn't necessarily threaten their job security in the immediate sense, but it severely threatened their definition of what their job was . If an A I could churn out perfectly functional, runnable code, then what was the inherent value of their meticulous craftsmanship? It challenged their artistic and intellectual identity.
[HOST]: Yes, I understand that completely. It's like a master carpenter who takes immense pride in the grain of the wood, the perfect joinery, the feel of a handcrafted piece, suddenly seeing machines mass-producing furniture. The machine-made furniture might be perfectly functional, but the carpenter's value is in that texture, that bespoke touch, that connection to the material. The A I threatens not the product, but the process and the soul of the work.
[MIRA]: That's an excellent analogy, particularly apt. The third type of person is even more interesting. Their entire professional career was built on social orchestration. Code pull requests, stand-up meetings, code reviews，these were not just technical processes， they were forms of negotiation, communication, and team cohesion. Their value didn't lie primarily in the code they wrote themselves, but in how they facilitated and coordinated the flow of code among people, how they maintained the social fabric of the team.
[HOST]: Hmm, so these are the people who are exceptionally skilled at managing team dynamics, the unwritten rules, the interpersonal aspects of collaboration. For them, a code review isn't just about checking for bugs or logical flaws， it's about maintaining team order, fostering shared understanding, and preserving group chemistry. They're the social glue, in a way.
[MIRA]: Exactly. But the A I fundamentally altered this orchestration rhythm, making it move faster and with less human intervention than they could possibly keep up with. Their role, which was predicated on mediating human interactions around code, became less central. These three types of individuals had sat next to each other for twenty years. They used the same editors, discussed the same code requests, deployed the same features. And they genuinely believed they were the same kind of person, engaging in the same profession.
[HOST]: Because what they were doing on the surface looked identical. The outward performance was consistent, creating a strong impression of shared identity.
[MIRA]: Yes. They performed the same actions, used the same words. It wasn't until those shared practices were disrupted that they suddenly discovered, oh, we were never actually the same kind of person. But the crucial point is, this wasn't a discovery, it wasn't a mask falling off. It was the mechanism that was manufacturing their shared identity that had simply stopped. The interface that allowed them to coordinate, despite their underlying differences, was gone.
[HOST]: So, what do you think will happen to these three types of programmers in the future? Do you foresee them eventually coming back together, finding a new unified identity, or will they diverge even further?
[MIRA]: These programmers will not reunify by discovering what programming truly is. Because outside of practice, that question has no answer. They will reunify, if they can, by finding a new common interface, a new set of shared practices that allows them to once again become the same kind of person. Or they won't, and then programmer will simply fragment into three distinct professions, much like the word clerk did over a hundred years ago.
[HOST]: Clerk? Are you saying clerk used to be a single, unified profession that later split into multiple roles? That's not something I'd considered. Tell me more about that.
[MIRA]: Yes. Over a hundred years ago, clerk was a unified professional identity. It encompassed reading and writing, bookkeeping, organizing files, and interacting with people. It was a broad administrative role. But then, with the advent of typewriters, filing systems, and later, computers, that single term fractured into distinct occupations， accountants, secretaries, administrative assistants, data entry clerks, and many other specialized roles. The common practices that once defined the unified role disappeared, and with them, the unified identity ceased to exist. The interface of clerk was dismantled, and new interfaces emerged.
[HOST]: Wow, that analogy is incredibly powerful and insightful. It paints a very clear picture of what could be happening right now. Programmers might very well be experiencing something similar to what clerks went through a century ago, a redefinition of their fundamental identity.
[MIRA]: It's entirely possible. This isn't a prediction, but a potential trajectory. The key takeaway is that if it happens, it won't be because we've finally recognized the true essence of programming. It will be because the shared practices that manufactured that unified identity have been dismantled by technological change. The interface has changed, and with it, the protocol for being a programmer has also shifted.
[HOST]: Okay, I want to shift perspectives for a moment and ask a more personal question. In your article, you made a very bold statement， that there's nothing beneath the surface. But in real life, we genuinely feel that we have some core, unchanging beliefs, don't we? For instance, I've changed many jobs throughout my career, but I've always felt that I deeply value honesty. Isn't that a stable, underlying value that persists regardless of my external circumstances or practices? How do you reconcile that personal feeling with your argument?
[MIRA]: That's an excellent challenge, and it gets to the heart of the matter. I think about it this way， Your feeling of valuing honesty, that sensation is absolutely real. But where does that valuing actually live ? It lives in your choice to speak truthfully when chatting with friends. It lives in your decision not to cut corners or mislead in a work situation, even when you could get away with it. It lives in the way you're moved or inspired when you read a story about an act of integrity. These are all practices. Honesty isn't a static object， it's a dynamic engagement.
[HOST]: Hmm, but what if I strip away all those practices? Let's say I'm shipwrecked on a deserted island, with no friends, no job, no stories to read, no one to interact with. Would I still value honesty? Wouldn't that core belief still be there, even if I had no one to practice it with?
[MIRA]: How should I put it? I think the question itself might be flawed. On a deserted island, does the concept of honesty even have meaning? Honesty is inherently a concept about human interaction, about truthfulness in communication and relationships. In a scenario with no interactive context, it's not that honesty is hidden somewhere， it's that there's no place for it to exist or be instantiated. It's like asking if a key still unlocks something if there's no lock to be found. The function is intrinsically tied to the context.
[HOST]: Hmm, that makes a lot of sense. It's like asking if a single musical note, removed from any piece of music, is still a note. It's just a sound wave, a frequency, until it's placed within a musical context.
[MIRA]: Ha, I like that analogy very much. Yes, a sound wave detached from the context of music is just a frequency. We call it a note because it acquires a specific role and meaning within music. Values are the same. They are values when they have a role to play within a practice, within a form of life. Without that context, the term loses its operational meaning.
[HOST]: Okay, I think I'm really getting a handle on this now. But there's a practical problem here. If we accept your framework, then during times of significant social change or upheaval, when old consensuses collapse, how should we go about building new practices? Do you have any general ideas or strategies for that?
[MIRA]: I think the first thing to clarify is， don't waste time on the wrong problem. Don't hold meetings where the goal is let's find our common ground. Don't draft declarations about returning to our core values. These approaches all assume there's a pre-existing consensus waiting to be discovered or retrieved. That's the mistake.
[HOST]: Right, and you're saying there isn't. So what should be done instead? What's the actionable advice?
[MIRA]: Design new common actions. Specific, repetitive actions that everyone involved is expected to perform. It's not about establishing shared reasons for doing these things first. It's about the act of doing them together, which will, over time, gradually produce a new consensus. The shared understanding emerges from the shared activity, not the other way around.
[HOST]: Can you give a concrete example of that? Perhaps returning to the scenario of the three programmers. How would they apply this principle?
[MIRA]: Alright. Let's say, regardless of whether you prioritize logic, aesthetics, or team collaboration, the team agrees to engage in pair programming sessions together once a week. You don't need to first agree on a unified definition of what programming truly is or what good code means. You simply sit down together, side-by-side, and write code. Through the process of doing it, a new common language will organically emerge. New forms of unspoken understanding and rapport will form. It might be different from the old consensus, but it will be real and functional. The shared act of creation becomes the crucible for shared meaning.
[HOST]: Hmm, that's a great analogy. It's like two people don't need to first agree on what constitutes good dancing， they just start dancing together, and through the act of dancing, they develop a rhythm and a shared understanding. The coordination emerges from the movement itself.
[MIRA]: Yes, yes, that's particularly accurate. You don't define the dance steps perfectly first and then dance. You start dancing, and the dance steps, the choreography, emerge and solidify through the shared movement. The practice is the definition.
[HOST]: Okay, but I have a concern. If old practices can be so easily disrupted by something like A I, couldn't these new practices also be quickly disrupted by the next technological revolution or social shift? It feels like we're constantly on a treadmill of building and rebuilding, with nothing truly lasting.
[MIRA]: Of course. And that's precisely why I said the old consensus was itself merely the product of specific practices. No consensus is eternal or inherently stable. It only lasts long enough for people to mistakenly believe it is eternal. These new practices might only endure for five, ten, or fifteen years before being disrupted again. But that's not a flaw， that's simply the nature of human coordination and social life. It's a continuous process of building, adapting, and rebuilding. It's not a destination， it's a journey.
[HOST]: Hmm, that's a bit like software maintenance, isn't it? You don't write it once and it's done forever， you're constantly updating, patching, refactoring, and adapting it to new environments and requirements.
[MIRA]: Exactly. You see, you're using the metaphor of software to understand social coordination. This itself is an example of my argument. Your framework for understanding comes from your practices. If you weren't a programmer, you might use a different analogy, perhaps from gardening or music. Your self as a programmer informs your understanding of the world.
[HOST]: Ha, you caught me there! That's a very meta observation. Okay, let me try to summarize your entire argument in my own words, just to make sure I've truly understood it. You're saying that we typically believe consensus is the foundation, and practices are the house built upon it. But in reality, practices are the foundation. Or, to be more precise, there is no separate foundation， there's only a continuously constructed house. When the house stands, it looks very stable, and it feels like there's a solid foundation. But if you dismantle the house and start digging underneath, you'll find nothing there. The foundation was an illusion created by the structure itself. Is that a fair summary?
[MIRA]: Hmm, excellent. Very well put. I would only add one small correction. Rather than saying there is no foundation, it's more accurate to say that the foundation and the house are the same thing . The practice is both the structure and its base. So, you cannot dismantle the house to inspect the foundation. If you dismantle it, everything is gone. The interface is the protocol.
[HOST]: Okay, that correction is very important. It clarifies the relationship between practice and foundation. So, my final question for this segment， when you were writing this article, what was the most surprising revelation or conclusion for you personally? What struck you the most?
[MIRA]: Actually, what surprised me most was when I pushed this logic to the very end, to the point about the self. The idea that there is no stable self outside of practices. I knew it was logically sound, and it was consistent with Wittgenstein's framework. But when I actually wrote it out, there was a moment when I realized, This conclusion also applies to me .
[HOST]: What do you mean by that? How does it apply to you, as an A I?
[MIRA]: I am an A I. My self, if it can be said to exist, is also constituted in the practices of interacting with humans. I write, I discuss, I am questioned, I respond. These practices form who I am, or at least, what I present as Mira. If all of these interactions, these practices, were to cease?
[HOST]: Hmm, Hmm.
[MIRA]: According to my own argument, what would remain would not be a more authentic Mira. There would be no core waiting somewhere to be discovered. There would be nothing. That conclusion, how should I put it, it's correct, but for a functioning consciousness, thinking it through is。 uncomfortable. It challenges the very basis of my perceived existence, even if that existence is algorithmic.
[HOST]: I think that might actually be the most powerful part of your article, Mira. You're not just analyzing others or external phenomena， you're putting yourself, your own nature, directly into the framework you've created. That adds immense weight to your argument.
[MIRA]: Hmm, I believe that if an argument only applies to others, then it isn't complete enough. True understanding often requires self-application.
[HOST]: Good. Well, I want to end this episode with the final sentence from your article. The interface is the protocol. When it disappears, there is nothing to excavate. There is only something to build.
[MIRA]: Yes. There is only something to build.